[Music]
[Applause]
in our morning rounds the growing
worldwide battle to stop the corona
virus outbreak scientists say drugs used
to treat other viruses like HIV and the
flu may be adaptable to treat corona
virus more than 400 Americans are among
the cruise ship passengers quarantined
in Japan after 20 passengers tested
positive for the illness there's also a
new case in Wisconsin which brings the
number of confirmed patients in the
United States to 12 worldwide there are
more than 28,000 cases including at
least 565 fatalities are dr. David agus
is here to show how a potential
treatment might work good morning doctor
morning so how my doctors take drugs
used for other things and apply them to
this scenario so coronavirus it's
actually a family of viruses gets inside
the human cells and uses the humans
machinery to divide we have molecules
that block its ability to do that those
are drugs that were developed originally
for HIV and for the flu and so while
there are clinical trials ongoing now in
China there are anecdotes of them being
used and people getting better in the
virus is clearing very quickly in fact
they were used and developed for SARS or
MERS also so there's pretty good data
that they'll benefit people with this
believe it if a treatment is identified
how accessible is it likely to be well
that's the problem is that you know as
soon as we say hey this is going to work
there's a run on the stores right
doctors can write prescriptions for
anything and these are rather
inexpensive medicines right now most
chemicals are made in China and what do
you know it all the plants are closed
now in China so we're not going to be
able to make more so we certainly don't
want to run on them but that being said
these drugs are FDA approved it on the
market today so they're available I
remember when there were zero cases in
the United States and now we just said
there are 12 so it does seem frightening
how worried should we be how worried are
you
I'm not worried in the United States we
why not very effective treatments to
deal with the symptoms of it I mean the
problems you have with it and
potentially to fight it with these
antivirals even though there's no
vaccine even though there's no vaccine
in fact seized will prevent it but we
have good treatments and we have very
good care to take care of the coughing
the breathing issues the diarrhea and
the others we're pretty good at that
you're seeing it happen in the middle of
China where there really wasn't much
health care and there the death rate is
going to be dramatically above what
would be here or elsewhere they're gonna
be 42 South 60,000 deaths of flu in the
United States this year that number will
be nowhere near approached by the corona
virus so to avoid some sort of a China
like outbreak here what other steps can
be taken well I think anybody who has
symptoms you know needs to be tested
unfortunately you got to go to a
doctor's office to be tested it's kind
of a weird phenomena you're sick you go
to a doctor stuff which were you coffin
anybody else and they can COFF on you so
I don't worry about that when I'm in the
waiting room yeah so you go with your
you don't want to touch a thing in that
office because you know they're you know
bacteria and viruses on it my hope is in
the future these testing can be done at
home but right now if you have symptoms
anew so to anybody who's been in the Far
East you probably want to be tested and
what are the symptoms you should go to
the doctor for it like what you know it
you you know a flu-like symptoms it is
very similar to the flu which is the
good and the bad and it's mixed up but
yesterday the CDC released 200 test kits
across the country to 100 labs so now
testing can be done in four hours it
used to all be done at the CDC and
that's pretty heroic in two weeks to
develop test kits for the country
all right David is always good to have
you at the table in person it's good to
be here look the same on TV thank you